very excited to uh to be joined by our
next guest uh
a buddy of mine for many years we've
shared a lot of
nba games together a lot of people don't
know this guy is a
huge sports fan very knowledgeable when
it comes to all things
uh all things patriots and mets and
almost had an opportunity to join the
bucks tape was going to leave the new
york knicks fandom
to go be a bucks fan at one point didn't
take it though
didn't do it josh ostrowski aka the fat
jewish my dear friend joins the show
right now remember that i mean when
you're thinking about joining the bucks
tape that was a long time ago buddy
i had had enough okay a lot of years
a lot of trauma and it was yes sometimes
you think about doing
crazy things and you know what i think
i'd be pretty happy right now
because instead of a first round loss
and instead of julius randle getting
bodied up by danilo galinari
i would be with bobby portis and his
psychotic eyes
celebrating a world championship so
maybe i should have you spent a lot of
time in milwaukee over the years you've
been to some bucks games
uh what were your thoughts on the deer
district i know you do great in crowds
you know what's really funny is actually
so yeah my uh
my ex-wife who was uh she was from
wisconsin you know very broad shoulder
you know something something in the milk
out there they build them big you know
[Laughter]
i went to uh very sturdy she's not
blowing over in a storm you know
legs like redwoods and i spent a lot of
time out there and actually you know
funny enough
their fans are like you know they're
complete maniacs you know they're all
hanging out like
you know they eat at casino buffets
they're beautiful americans honestly i
celebrate them truly which was another
reason
that i thought about defecting and you
know it's interesting i saw
in in new york once i saw i saw the
greek freak
i saw giannis in a greek restaurant uh
called pilos in the east village and
he's eating an
entire branzino like just a beautiful
branzino
you know and i walked up to him and i
think his manager kind of knew who i was
he had no idea who i was
and he was like oh you could do it from
instagram and i said to giannis
i said yo and i named of a greek
restaurant in milwaukee
and his eyes lit up and he and he said
yo the greek food in milwaukee is
horrible
and then i pitched him on coming to new
york simply
because the souvlakian milwaukee is like
eating leather and he couldn't believe
that i knew the name of this restaurant
and i think i really thought i got
through to him and i really thought i
could lure him to new york but guess
what it didn't work
no no the guy was loving smoothies i
wasn't expecting him to have a delicious
moussaka out there
if he was going to get that it was going
to be back in new york we've had a lot
of fun memories at the garden eating 15
john george chicken sandwiches let me
tell you i remember going to fan
appreciation night when they gave out
free food
at the end of the game uh you've now
upgraded to the spike lee seats uh what
have been some of your favorite
encounters with players while watching
games at the garden
oh man so you know actually i one of my
most prized possessions is they give you
they now give you a blue card when you
get a warning they used to just give you
a warning they'd be like shut up you big
fat clown
now they tell you shut up you big fat
clown to me and they also give you a
blue card that says all thing on it if
you get warned again you're gonna get
thrown out
and i've started collecting them and so
you know if you go too hard
you're going to get thrown right out but
to get the blue card it's the perfect
mix of sort of pg-13
um you know i talked to i got into white
howard's head about how tiny his jersey
was like why are his jerseys always so
small
uh zach randolph for looking like a
ninja turtle um
you know i once you know started oh i
told i streamed on um you know
one of your favorite players of all time
landry fields after he signed a big
contract with toronto no idea why they
would do that
that he should spend some of his new
money on me if benihana got into a fight
with his fiancee
he called me a bad person uh matt barnes
once threatened to kill me i mean there
have been some really incredible
memories at the gardens
i remember going down to uh the john
wall jeremy lin rematch for lynn sanity
with you we drove down to dc outside the
white house
spending some time at the uh they were
giving out free chicken sandwiches from
the sky
at the uh at the wizards game remember
that they had the parachutes of the
chicken sandwiches
you know it's really crazy how it's
crazy how few incredible memories we
have together we've gone to so many
games and yet it's like the chicken time
we got a free chicken sandwich
the seven games that will insanity
happen like there's so few incredible
memories
that's that's what it means to be a
knick fan what are we gonna sit here and
have you come on the show and we can
talk about lou amundsen no we don't need
to do that
um let's talk about this world of comedy
in sports a lot of people you know know
you from instagram now which is insane
to me and always brings a smile to my
face as you know
uh but but a lot of people don't know
you're a die hard sports fan
what's it been like in to connect with
other players in sports guys like blake
griffin who i know your friend
are friends with you know and do some
comedy stuff and
and also have your you know your your
sports dreams come to life
yeah it's been pretty awesome you know
it's like you know when you're a zealous
celebrity like me you know life on the z
list you can really
you can really slide into the dms of
some like not you know you're just i'm
not connecting with top tier players
like you know
zion is not responding to my dm's like
you have them all the time i want to
know how the muffalatas are down in new
orleans
he never reads them he never responds
obviously but i can get
you know i can get into the dms of some
lesser-known players
and and you know across all sports um
and we can hang out like
you know like did i go did i go to p.f
chang's with lesean mccoy i sure did
um you know i've been able to cultivate
some real memories because you know i'm
sliding in i got a blue check mark
so they see it and they're like oh this
guy got a lot of followers um and a lot
of these guys uh you know there's kind
of hanging out we can really uh we can
get together and make some memories some
of them are not all that
busy um and so you know some of the some
of the more b-list and retired guys want
to hang out and have a maybe have a
sleepover so
i've gotten to connect with a lot of a
lot of cool dudes none of them
top tier maybe blake griffin's probably
the best player i've ever really hung
out with well now i would imagine you're
part of the nba wine circles as the
co-founder of babe which sold to
budweiser uh what are some of your
favorite nba wines
well i would really more like to talk
about who are some of my favorite nba
player sommeliers um obviously cj
mccollum incredible palette
i mean his his nose you know when he
smells a big body of barolo he really an
audacious barolo he really knows
how to enjoy he had to have his room set
at the appropriate temperature down in
the bubble to maintain the flavor in the
pinot noir
he turned his room into an actual
temperature-controlled wine cellar
he loves a buttery chardonnay you know
he loves something with a lot of legs
and a lot of body
obviously you know lebron's wine cellar
super famous um i actually
have an incredible story there's a
there's a uh kind of is an a-list
celebrity i know
lebron you know flint is there dm years
ago so i'd like to see you i'd like you
to see my wine cellar i think it might
be a pick-up line of his i'm really not
sure
um and so there's a lot of guys now who
love wine i mean it used to be just true
bledsoe and now it's really everybody
channing frye sasha booya kevin loves no
what
mellow oh you sent me you sent me a
photo of sasha blyach in a cowboy hat
drinking i believe uh he might have been
drinking a malbec
in like a vineyard like somewhere
outside of santa rosa and i was like
this is incredible i framed it it's in
my home
alexander bliss don't do tastings if you
want to go have a pinot with sasha but
you can get a nice bottle for your buddy
um you and i do like to send each other
fun photos and instagram videos i sent
you a
a video of ronaldo bachmann off cameo
wishing you congratulations for your
wedding
uh what are you working on these days
what kind of memorabilia might i expect
sending my way soon you know a couple
different things one of the one of my
favorite things i sent you recently
obviously was the inexplicable release
of the
at the air langston galloway shoe now i
know the proceeds are going to like a
good cause and it's all very good
but i don't know who did the design but
they are some of the most
it's like wearing two diapers on your
feet they are the absolute
most busted shoes i like why is langston
gala coming out with a shoe
i'm obviously going to cop a pair
because i'm a i'm a collector of bad
shoes i have like 10 pairs of
strawberries that i got stephen barry's
back in the day
you know free whales with the spinners
you know i have a lot of you know
anything that was horrible that ever
came out but uh
things you can expect for me um coming
up in the near future you know actually
you guys were talking about that plane
flight that's really interesting do you
think
like i didn't even i don't i saw a guy
one time on a plane i went to high
school with and i almost had a panic
attack we didn't even talk imagine being
on the plane with these guys who just be
in the finals like they're probably not
all syncing up a movie and watching it
together right like pressing play at the
same time
no i don't think so i think there's a
great nancy myers movie that
devin booker is sharing in the back of
the plane it's chris
you got do you guys want to watch under
the tuscan sun or like i'm basically
down for whatever and chris middleton is
like get out of my
my actual face um it's probably it's
definitely gotta be pretty awkward i'll
probably send you
more cameos patrick ewing notoriously
does the absolute worst cameos in the
world
the tv's on in the back you can hear
like a commercial for like a rental car
company
he's the most low energy the camera is
like at his chin
very boomer like below his face and he's
like happy birthday melinda and you're
hearing like a celino and barnes
commercial blaring and you turn the tv
off
like somebody paid 45 dollars for this
turn off the tv
like come on patrick so you'll probably
be getting a lot more of those for me
pictures of alexis fed you know how it
goes
oh love alexis fed's instagram a great
follow on social media at
the fat jewish joins the show josh
ostrowski ben lions filling in for rich
on the rich eisen show
i remember watching the 2011 nba finals
game four meltdown from lebron with you
in a bank in brooklyn uh underneath the
kanye west show
i've watched some weird nba finals games
with you over the years
where have been some of the strange
places you've watched super bowls
because you were a patriots fan
in new york city all those years yeah it
was a pretty it was pretty hard my
family
my family my family hates me i mean not
because of that but also because of that
in addition to some other things but
yeah it was it was really hard i mean i
come from a family of jet fans my
my dad wears like a 4x kevin maui jersey
i mean these guys are real dirtbags and
they were
you know really wanted to disown me i
mean look it's when i went to
you know i wasn't i went to sort of an
artistic school in new york not a lot of
sports fans when i was in middle school
and at jewish summer camp you know
obviously where
a young jewish boy learns everything he
knows i was with a bunch of guys from
north alabama massachusetts
and you know they were diehard teddy
brewski fans i picked it up and uh you
know i entered into an
i made an absolutely horrible choice in
the summer of 95 that i can now not go
back on
and i can never undo the past but it's
been it's been really really hard yeah
it's not it's it's a lot i have a lot of
trauma i feel like now i'm talking to my
therapist like this is good actually
josh ostrovsky joins the show at the fat
jewish on instagram when
for people who follow you uh uh you know
on instagram now which is like 11
million people on earth which is just so
stupid
um when did you start to notice that it
was like making a change i remember
going to nick games with you and it
started to be
you know a thing that you were at the
game so when did you start to feel
your life starting to change from
instagram um well i'm gonna go back i'm
gonna go back one i'm gonna tell you
real quick my weirdest
my weirdest at my weirdest super bowl
viewing story
uh went to the south of france
i was invited by some uh some saudi
arabian guys i used to have a thing
where if you dm'd me
and i had a time in my schedule i would
basically go and do whatever you invited
to not for money just to make memories
and so you know i got myself in some
very weird situations but i wanted to
meet new people and have weird
experiences and people invite me to all
kinds of bizarre stuff
and they think i'm not going to respond
because they think with an account as
big as mine
that i'm never going to see it so they
get drunk and they're like you're never
going to see this
you're the worst and then i'm like
actually i read all my dms because i'm a
petty weight champion
and i saw this and i like i'm down to
roast you and so these uh guys from the
middle east invited me
i flew out to france i went on a yacht
they actually had
a live they had a um a lot
an ostrich on their on their yacht
they're like do you want to see
something crazy
and i go downstairs they have a live
ostrich on the boat
and the ostrich's name i'm not kidding
you was bradley cooper because they were
a huge bradley cooper fans american
actor bradley cooper
and i then sat on a boat with an ostrich
and watched the super bowl with them on
like a 100 inch flat screen
and i'm looking around going they flew
me out there and i'm going where am i
like this seems like a very questionable
very very questionable decision so
instagram has led me
to a lot of wild places um i'm trying to
think like the first time
the first i remember i was in the west
village and i was kind of day drunk i
had been you know kind of doing sort of
a sexist city brunch style
and someone ran up to me and put their
hands over my eyes from behind and was
like
yes oh and i was like what is happening
i was kind of smacked and i turned
around
and it was fran drescher and i think in
that moment i realized like wow
people are really seeing this stuff like
you know you kind of when you have a big
account you post and you think it's just
for your idiotic friends you know like
you
but you don't realize fran drescher's
looking too and sometimes when i think
about it it makes me it makes me nervous
i'm like is friend gonna like this what
if friend unfollows me like what a
friend
because she's an icon it should be on
mount rushmore and i think at that
moment
i realized wow this is really really
wild no that was like
you're giannis getting the mvp last
night in the championship but finally a
culmination of work
a lifetime of sacrifice the nanny came
up to you after brunching in soho
uh ben lyon's here on the rich eisen
show joined by josh ostrovsky
where were you when you found out the
news that carmelo went to portland
i don't know only you would know that
you psycho nobody cared about that like
i was i am so
you know you need to just you he needs
to hire you the amount of pressure the
amount of pub you're doing for this guy
like i wake up at like first of all it's
eight o'clock in the morning in new york
it's five in l.a i don't know why you're
up
and you're sending me a text being like
did you know fun facts of the morning
carmelo anthony is the leader in all
time in team usa
minutes logged when the team registered
a win of more than 10 points and i'm
like
it doesn't literally matter the guy went
to one western conference final he's a
trash man
you are doing constant pr for this guy
the day he came to the knicks
you cried in a bar i'm sorry i have a
photo of you eating a sandwich named
after him with la la at the carnegie
deli so let's challenge flag on the
field right now hold on hold on
when you're with an american hero like
lala anthony
okay i'm a huge wildlife fan am i not
allowed to split the two and she put me
on the spot
by the way you put a pastrami sandwich
in a fat jewish guy's face and then as
it was in my mouth you went
this is called the carmelo anthony and
what was i gonna do i couldn't
disrespect him like that although
honestly
i really wanted to because outside of
amari sotomayor who by the way i don't
know if you now you know
he's a rabbi and a farmer um there's
really no nick that i've ever hated more
and you know that sir no i know i know
you've had some encounters with amari
down in the meatpacking district and it
wasn't in a wine
in a wine spa i'll tell you that uh josh
i appreciate you
joining the show you think we'll get a
knicks title in our in our lifetime
all right ben it's been great thanks so
much
rich eisen you're a beautiful man thank
you and the answer your question is
absolutely
not although look you know we do have
the 20th pick so like you know what's
gonna happen this year it's gonna be
magical oh yeah by the way
congratulations on being a father i
haven't had a chance to talk to you in
real life you had to use this
show as an excuse to say congratulations
i just i just want to note by the way
that i gave my son the middle name of
kelby
to represent the late and great kobe
bryant okay i want you to know that
i wrote for la on that and uh it's
really really scary
that i am somebody's father i think i
sent you the birth announcement within
the first three days of being born i put
him on a giant hoagie and pretended he
was to eat him on a sandwich so
that kid's going to be in 600 an hour
therapy within the next couple years so
it's an exciting time for me
not really for him well we're 20 years
away from buddy kobe king getting a
four-year 200 million dollar deal from
the knicks after he blows out an
achilles with you on a jet ski so
looking forward to that yeah
he's jewish so he's not an athlete
thanks for joining the show josh
thank you for joining the show
appreciate it love that guy
grew up with josh so much fun when you
see your friends who have been ridiculed
chastised for being themselves for years
get a chance to now enjoy life like this
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here